to show yourself you have to know
yourself what does this mean let me let
me Circle back on something to answer
that
um I was trained in the theater
and it was the serious theater and I'm
not making fun of that but it was I mean
we thought we were going to change the
world
doing theater it was a real passion for
me
and still is I I love it and I I do it I
still do it occasionally but you don't
have to show yourself in the theater you
show the character you show
your version of that character
but in film and television you have you
you can't escape showing yourself
and the minute you try to escape it you
look terrible as I said my my first few
TV things that I watched were just I
thought at least to my standards I
thought were really bad I thought oh I
have a lot to learn and so to know your
you know you can't when I teach because
I do like you can't teach someone about
their identity uh I'm not talking about
identity sexual identity I'm talking
about personal identity
um you can't teach that but you can
curate it a little bit and I do think
I always say you know lead
and examine life do something that's
outside of this
acting stuff
plant a garden refinish a piece of
furniture do something tangible do
something and read and and create
uh Heroes for yourself I always say
artistic Heroes they don't have to be
actors or they can be musicians they can
be art visual artists
so to know yourself I think when you get
older and I am older uh I'm really old
uh you I think it's a natural process
you get to know yourself better if if
you're open to that some people just
aren't some people never know themselves
I'm not talking about those people but
you know the more enlightened
self-examined person and you naturally
get to the truth about you
later in life you just and as an actor
uh that it it kind of becomes easier
because you don't have to
Push It Forward you don't have to push
it out it's just there it just lives
with you but when you're younger
you don't have any of that you're trying
to impress you're trying to be something
bigger greater grander uh you're trying
to
you're just constantly trying to figure
out who you are
I mean some people look some people
never know who they are some people know
who they are the minute they're born I
mean that there's a wide spectrum of
that but I do think to particularly if
we're talking about and we are talking
about acting and film acting in
particular
I think you do have to know
who you are and and it's it's
um
again hard to hard to
point to a finger to it but there are
certain people who have qualities
like we were just the other moment
talking about Tom Cruise and Will Smith
people like that
Tom Cruise who I happen to think is a
really good actor right kind of an
unpopular opinion in some circles but I
think he's very talented so do I yeah um
it's
who is he I don't really know who he is
but I do know that he is dead certain
about everything
he is certain he Harbors No Doubt
and that's a really attractive trait we
all want to be like that that's a
classic hero trade so whether he's
really like that I'm not sure but he's
awfully good at convincing me that he is
there's there's a there's a a certitude
about what he does
and to me that's kind of what makes a
star and there aren't too many stars
left in in the film world
so that core essential quality of in his
case dead certitude
you know has no doesn't question
now that doesn't question things but he
doesn't question what he has to do
that's so attractive to watch as you
know if you're if you're into Hero
Stories and and heroic stuff I don't
know if you saw the latest Top Gun
uh not yet it's great I mean it is what
it is it's it's it's a Thrill Ride but
it's great he's great in it and
um he combines that with a very high
level of skill
and so yeah he's I mean I I don't I've
never worked with him don't know him I
know people who have worked with him who
speak very highly of him in a work
environment
so I mean he's but there's so few people
like that I think because the system we
have
now it's it's all about imperfect he's
about perfection
he presents a perfect version of
um of himself in a way
we are much more interested in
imperfection I think as viewers we want
to see kind of the dirty messy stuff we
want to see the doubts we want to see
people having crises and so the classic
hero who has no
doubt and who knows what he or she has
to do is so rare today but I think it's
also like super attractive and I think
it's perennial I just think it's great
and even other rules that he was in that
weren't sort of the top gun Maverick
roles uh you know All the Right Moves
Risky Business
um still he had something in him where
you were just so drawn uh the firm and
at times he was being gaslit during the
and then he figured out okay wait a
minute exactly and and you went along on
that ride with him and yes he does have
this sort of unshakable where you're
like man I wish I could yeah he's going
to get it done right Tom's going to get
it done and he has Integrity too he has
Integrity in these roles like his his
characters always well let's not forget
Les Grossman and traffic Thunder have
you seen traffic Thunder I haven't
that was a that was a complete
um anomaly he plays this insane Studio
executive named Les Grossman
it's crazy and you go like oh you can do
that that's interesting right I've heard
of parts of the movie yeah I would now
I'll have to go not a movie you could
make today no politically correct
climate you could not make that movie
trailer yeah yeah right what's the
difference between an actor and an
authentic actor
um
an authentic actor is using him or
herself as the prism through which we
see the character
not unlike the story I told earlier
about the woman who said I just pretend
that what's happening is happening to me
I I interpret authenticness authenticity
authenticness is that a word I don't
even know it is now okay great I
interpret that as being something that
is
self-based in other words we want to
know how you
react to this situation it's personal it
is it is personal to you you're not
representing your you're not
transforming your informing if that
makes sense transformative acting the
kind that Meryl Streep sometimes gets to
do in Daniel Day Lewis and Anthony
Hopkins these are all incredible actors
most actors don't get a chance to do
that work because they just don't there
isn't that much of it and it goes to
those kind of folks
so we basically have to play
a truthful Dynamic version of Who We Are
to some extent to a large extent most of
the time and that is
the more you can lean into Who You Are
now it has to be mated
pardon me it has to be mated to a skill
set that that works and that is
[Music]
um
professional and and correct and that's
where I see
I do see a lot today
a diminution in that
and sort of basic skill set I have
actors where I will say
I'm not actually understanding what
you're saying
like it's not clear it's not vocally
it's not clear do you know what that
word means no well there's a dictionary
there's a thing called Google look it up
I want to you know I want you to be
there's a there's there's no lack of
reality and authenticity there is a lack
of imagination and curiosity not it's
not rampant but I see that I see people
who are incurious and don't want they
just think oh if I just behave naturally
it'll be cool it'll be like that'll be
no no that's not it that's just the base
level of realistic behavior is not
acting realistic behavior is just
Behavior
acting has a strategy you have to figure
out the actor has to figure out
where the scene's going
if if the scene is an aria what's the
high note and why where does it change
what's the pre you know this is how I
work with auditions which I do a lot of
I do a lot of private audition coaching
and I've done thousands of these now so
I figured it out and I've learned myself
you know you have to sometimes teach
yourself like oh I'm not doing that I
have to figure out how to do that but
like with an audition you get whatever
you get you get six or eight pages two
or three scenes whatever and no time to
really work on it
um
these are standard things but they may
not be standard to to you or your
listeners I say what's the moment before
what just happened before this scene
how does that inform how it starts so it
has to have a dynamic beginning it has
to be in the flow of what just happened
you may not have the screenplay you may
not even know that so you have to kind
of make it up and figure out what's the
tone of the speech what's the genre of
this piece what makes sense what could
be the moment before this happens then
where does the scene change and why and
how do you mark that so those are all
like strategy things that you have to be
well trained to understand and most
people are but you do get I do get some
people that are just
they it's not get that or you know I did
a
perfect example of this is I did a guest
star a couple years ago on big little
lies which was a fantastic show
and because it was a David Kelly show uh
who's one of the elite writer creators
in television I mean Ally McBeal and all
kinds of the shows
I know having worked I worked on a lot
of Stephen bochko shows back in the day
and you don't change a syllable you
don't change you could have the greatest
take in the world if one word is off
they don't print it gotta do it again
so the same thing I thought was David
Kelly and who I had worked for but a
long time previous
so I was encouraged that the director
this wonderful British woman named
Andrea Arnold who directed the season
that I was in
she really wanted the the first A.D this
this woman who was the first assistant
director said now just on my first day
on the session I just want you to know
that Andrea doesn't say action
and she doesn't say cut
I said oh well what does she say well
she's probably going to want you to talk
your way into the scene into the flow of
the beginning of the scene and when she
feels you're in the right place where
the scene begins she'll probably say
something like okay off you go
which is exactly what she did
it was so liberating because usually
it's like action and everyone like
tenses up and he
it was a fantastic way to work
and so I've I stole that from her in a
way I mean it's not an original idea but
to really talk your way particularly if
like now the actors are taping stuff on
the in their homes for auditions and so
I said let's improv into the scene just
cut out the stuff that's not on the page
when you actually edit it but then
you're in the flow of what just happened
and that's really screen acting is so
different because you're playing little
pieces of a pie you have a big pie with
all these pieces and you're playing this
little piece and this little piece and
this little piece and they're out of
sequence so you really have to figure
out where they fit
and I the other thing that I do that I
don't it's my idea I don't know if it's
an original idea so you know title if
you get two or three scenes title each
scene like each scene if it's as if it's
a movie as if it's a book give it a
title you can't play the title but it
puts it in context we have to understand
the story
when you're working on stage you're
doing the whole story every night from
beginning to middle to end when you're
working on film you're doing a little
tiny piece of the story here and a
little tiny piece of the story there so
you do have to understand the story what
is the story that you're telling what is
the story about and it's frankly much
harder I mean it's way harder
it's not an instinctive thing it's
something you do have to learn and you
have to practice and get better at and
you're doing different angles of it
let's do the take from this side and
yeah it's it's quite I have always found
it to be harder acting on stage for me
anyway is easy
scary
but it's easy because once the lights
come up I'm in control of the evening
I'm in control of what I have to do
I know where this has to go and I have a
working technique you develop a
technique on stage
that you also you develop a different
kind of technique for film but the
purpose of having a reliable technique
is it establishes a level below which
your work doesn't go
so it's a baseline level of of that and
so when I started in film
and I have referenced a couple times how
awful I thought I was at the beginning
it's because I was trying to take the
stage technique and and somehow make
that work
doesn't work it just doesn't work I had
to sort of figure out how to be more
present and how to be
how to work in close-up and and how to
not be presenting but how to be in it
and be alive in it and pretend that
what's happening is happening to me as
my former student said so that is what
that is and it's for some people it's
easy for people who don't have that
formal training it's kind of easier
but if you have that training and
background it's a shift it's a shift
so when you saw yourself whether it was
on tape or whatever besides you said not
maybe being president what else did you
feel like you were acting quote unquote
okay I did uh the first
show I ever did
was show it was a big hit in the 80s a
show called Heart to Heart oh yes yes
Daniel's Heart to Heart loved it and um
I didn't know what I was doing I got
this I came to La within six weeks I got
an agent within two more weeks I got my
first job I didn't know what I was doing
I was lucky very lucky
and I show up on the set and there's a
lot of waiting around and a lot of you
know like I'm I'm used to like let's go
let's go let's go
you know hours and hours of waiting
around for your scene and I didn't know
at that time how to sort of
um manage my time down which is a big
thing for actors because you got to stay
in the zone but you got to manage that
time
so that you're not so that you're ready
at a moment's notice so there was an
older actor whose name I don't remember
on the same episode a guy I'd seen in
like a hundred
westerns and an older guy
and I said hey this is my first job and
you know I'm not getting anything from
the director
he said listen kid if he's not telling
you anything you're doing great don't
worry about it so then I watched it six
or eight weeks later when I was on with
my wife and then everyone back home my
family back in Minnesota
and I was just mortified I thought I
looked I'm like one of those bad TV
actors I used to kind of look down my
nose at
and that was like a big aha moment and I
was really
I was really motivated by Vanity
I don't want to be that bad again I got
to be better than that I was it was like
vanity
and we all have that and so I went no
that's and so I don't know how it
happened
but I well I do kind of know how I found
that the first time I was working on a
show with the great actor late great
Jack Warden
who uh you kids at home look him up it
was an amazing actor w-a-r-d-e-n correct
me right right and Jack was just
I I I I was recurring on the show and I
just want to hang around him because I
thought he was such a great sure we
never talked about acting he only talked
about baseball and sports and he was a
great guy and he was mentoring me
without knowing he was mentoring me and
we were talking about we were sitting I
was sitting in my chair he was sitting
in his chair the set's over here they
just shot his close-up we're talking
about uh whatever baseball the weather
something and the director said oh Jack
you know what we I'm sorry you are going
to be in this shot in the back I'm going
to need you for this shot and they just
done Us close enough no problem he gets
up goes over to his place on the set
and I'm watching him and I'm thinking
that's the same guy I was just talking
to there's none of this there's none of
this performance there's none of this
it's just like boom he's just there the
same person
no difference I thought oh and I I at
lunch I sat and had lunch with him
because it took any chance I could to
hang around him
and I said I noticed this I said tell me
if I'm crazy but I noticed that and it
really blew my mind how
I guess relaxed is too uh is not as
strong enough for it but how focused
and how centered he was
he said yeah
it took me about 20 years to figure that
out I went okay I get it but I that was
like a big aha moment for me because I
was getting a master class from from a
great actor right he didn't know he was
giving me a master class but he was and
so that was I think that was as I think
back on it that was kind of the
beginning of my knowing oh it could just
I'm enough
I'm actually enough I don't have to I
don't have to push I don't I'm enough
but the I that you present the the you
that you present has to be interesting
then we go back to the idea of an
examined life and being a full human
being and not just being consumed by
ambition and craziness and show business
and all that stuff
so anyway there's that story